how can other people tap dance to work
what's the secret of that you find your
passion you find your passion I was very
very lucky to find a you know when I was
uh seven or eight years old and
fortunately my children have found their
passion my you know one son loves
farming like nothing else one son loves
music like everything else and and all
three of them love philanthropy and what
they get to do you're lucky in life when
you you find it and you can't guarantee
you're gonna find it your first job out
but I always tell college students to
come out I said take the job that you
would take if you were independently
wealthy you know that's you're going to
do well at it if you think you're going
to be a lot happier if you've got 2x
instead of X you're probably making a
mistake I mean you ought to find
something you like that's that works
with that and you'll get in trouble if
you think that making 10x or 20x is the
answer to everything in life because
then you will do things like borrow
money when you shouldn't or maybe cut
corners on on things that your employer
wants you to cut corners on it just
doesn't make any sense you won't like it
when you look back on it hey it's Evan
carmichaelin I make these videos because
in my first business I struggled to stay
afloat I quit my business partner and
the thing that kept me going was
studying the stories of famous
entrepreneurs and seeing how they
struggled and seeing what they had to
overcome and listen to their wisdom
motivation gave me the Courage the
strength the belief to go one more day
and see my business through and in all
honesty I still need the inspiration
wisdom motivation today for my business
too so today let's live your best
believe life and learn Warren Buffett's
secrets to success enjoy
free things and hiring people look for
integrity intelligence and energy and he
said if the person didn't have the first
two that the latter two would kill them
because if they don't have integrity you
want them dumb and lazy you don't want
them smart and energetic it never
bothered me if people disagreed with
what I thought as long as I felt I knew
the facts I mean there's a whole bunch
of things I don't know think about I
just stay away from those so I stay
within what I call my circle of
competence you know that Tom Watson said
it best he said you know he said he said
I'm no genius but I'm smart in spots and
I stay around those spots well I try and
stay around those spots and I I just
don't have a a problem if if uh if
somebody says you know you're wrong on
something I just I go back and look at
the facts and and
I think that I think that really is much
more important frankly than than having
a few points of IQ or or having an extra
course or two in in school or anything
of the sort you need emotional stability
what's your media routine I just read
and read and read I probably read five
to six hours a day I don't read as fast
now as as when I was younger but I read
five daily newspapers I read a fair
number of of magazines I read 10ks I
read annual reports and I read a lot of
other things too so I I I've always
enjoyed reading I love reading
biographies for example also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I designed a special
free worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
famous lesson about a margin of safety
that you don't drive a truck that weighs
9900 pounds across a bridge that says
limit ten thousand pounds because you
can't be that sure about it if you see
something like that you go down a little
further down the road and you find one
that says limit twenty thousand pounds
and that's the one you drive across the
nature of capitalism is that people want
to come in and take your capsules
perfectly understandable I mean if I'm
selling television sets or something
there's going to be 10 other people that
can try and sell a better television set
if I have a restaurant here in Omaha
people are going to try and copy my menu
and get more parking and take my chef
and so on so capitalism is all about
somebody coming and trying to take the
castle now what you need is you need a
castle that has some durable competitive
Advantage some castle that has a mode
around it and that moat that's one of
the best moats in many respects is to be
a low-cost producer but sometimes the
most is just having more talent I mean
if you're the heavyweight champion of
the world and keep knocking out people
you've got a competitive Advantage as
well if you can keep doing it and it's
very profitable uh if you're the one
that happens to be able to do it if you
can turn on great motion pictures I mean
you know Steven Spielberg I mean he he
he's a fellow to bet on and and it has
enormous economic value you'd be
surprised
at at my days I mean they are they're
very unstructured uh
no meetings uh none I mean we don't I
don't like meetings uh and uh
I read a lot uh I wish I were a faster
reader you know I get more done but I
but I do read a lot and I I I'm on the
phone a moderate amount uh uh our
businesses run themselves but basically
out there my job is allocating capital
and and I that's what I'm thinking about
uh but I don't like to have things all
packed hour to hour to hour and and Bill
and I are both extraordinarily lucky I
mean we really get to do what we like to
do the way we want to do it with people
we choose to be around and that are
terrific I mean we we've really got
everything
uh our way and it's it we're very
fortunate and in his world he has some
he has a different kind of pace than I
have but we both love it the way we do
it and and uh
my guess is that we're each the most
productive in that particular mode too
because it it it it it it fits our
personalities and and aptitudes well
what kills great businesses if you look
at
I do believe in looking at history and I
I and I try to I like to study failure
actually my partner says all I want to
know is where I'll die so I'll never go
there and and we want to see what has
caused businesses to go bad and the
biggest thing that kills them is
complacency I mean you you want a a
restlessness a feeling that you know
that
that somebody's always after you but
you're going to stay ahead of them you
always want to be on the move and and uh
when you've got a great business you
know like Coca-Cola which is there
aren't any like a girl but but
you really the danger would always be
that you rushed on your laurels but I
see none of that obviously at Coca-Cola
but that that is the key to compete the
same way when you've got 1.8 billion
servings being sold daily as when you
were selling you know 10 a day and and
that restlessness that belief that that
tomorrow is more exciting than today you
know you just have to have it permeate
the organization who was Ben Graham he
was your primary Mentor model
it was a wonderful man and he was my
professor at Columbia I read his book
when I was 19 at the University of
Nebraska and
I'd started investing when I was 11 and
I started reading about it when I was
like seven so I'd gone through all I
read every book in the Omaha Public
Library that was on by the time I was 12
on on investing in stock market and I
had a lot of fun but I never really
found out I never got grounded in
anything and it was it was entertaining
but it wasn't going to be profitable and
then I read Graham's book The
intelligent investor when I was at the
University of Nebraska and pulled up
just opened the whole thing up to me
yeah and I and I named my my oldest son
is named Howard after my dad Graham
Buffett and he was a marvelous man I
never expected anything from me in
return he just did all these things for
younger people Ben Graham and his little
in his little teens looked around and he
looked at the people he admired and he
said you know I want to be admired so
why don't I just behave like them and
they found there was nothing impossible
about behaving like them and similarly
he did the same thing on on the reverse
side in terms of getting rid of those
qualities you have given
um a lot of
fabulous advice but what's the best
advice that you've ever received
well I I received in a variety of forms
particularly from my father when I was
very young but I mean he basically I
think taught me how to live and I
thought I did it perfectly or anything
like that but I mean he was giving me
lessons but he wasn't doing it by
preaching to me he was doing it by
example but basically
uh well the biggest lesson in a sense I
got is the power of unconditional love I
mean I think there is no power on earth
like unconditional love and I think that
if if you offer that to your child I
mean you're 90 of the way home and maybe
days when you don't feel like it it's
not uncritical love that's a different
animal but but to know you'll always can
come back I mean that that is huge in
life that takes you a long long way and
I would say that every parent out there
that that can extend that to their child
at a very young age it's going to make
for a better human being and you felt
like you've got that kind of
unconditional love from your dad I
absolutely did yeah that was a powerful
thing it is a powerful thing
you have a competitive Spirit clearly
yeah
clearly well but you gotta you gotta be
careful about what you compete in you
know it's a good thing I don't have a
competitive Spirit In chess or you know
you know or football or anything like
that oh I just I I I'm an observer there
I I enjoy watching things like that
but I I try to keep my competitive
experience in a game where I can win do
you have a killer instinct
nah not exactly I've got I wouldn't call
it a Killer Instinct but I do I do know
this well I want to do something I
always want to do it big
I put my whole net worth in City service
preferred you know 120 dollars
114.75 and I put my whole net worth and
and I've never
since I was
well since that day and
you know March 11
1942. I have never had less than 80
percent of my money in American business
you can call them stocks or equities but
I see them as American Business I I've
owned a piece of American Business
for
eight at least 80 percent
at all times and you know I just I don't
want to own anything else I want to own
a home and you know things my family
wants and all that but owning five homes
doesn't mean anything to me because I'm
you can be happy in one home and there's
a certain amount of things that go wrong
with everything and if I got two homes I
know I've got more problems and I don't
have more happiness what brings you to
happiness oh that
I would have to be honestly say that the
the what makes me happiest is what I'm
doing what I'm doing you know I I
allocating I employ two things about it
one
and all went over time that's mean I'll
beat everybody else or anything like
that but I'll I I mean the game is very
very very easy if you have the right
lessons in your mind about what you're
buying I'm not buying stocks on my
pieces of overwhelmingly American
Business uh and I'm happy
when I was happy when that's uh when I'm
doing it I'm happy when stocks are going
down I'm happier when stocks are going
down because I I can buy more of them
with the same amount of money I'd be
happy if I was a farmer I'd want
Farmland to go down uh so I could buy
more acreage you know if I was I mean it
just makes sense we don't prepare
ourselves for a single problem we
prepare ourselves for problems that
that sometimes create their own momentum
I mean 2008 and a nine
he didn't see all the problems the first
day
when uh
really what really kicked it off was
when the the Freddie and Fanny the gses
went into conservatorship in early
September and and then when
uh
money markets funds broke the buck I
mean
there are
there are things to trip other things
and and we take a very much a worst case
uh
scenario into mind that probably is a
considerably worse case than than most
people do so I don't look at as as huge
and I'm not
I'm not recommending that people buy
stocks today or tomorrow or next week or
next month I think it all depends on
your circumstances but you shouldn't buy
stocks unless you expect in my view
you expect to hold them for a very
extended period and you are prepared
financially and psychologically
to hold them
the same way you would hold a farm and
never look at a quote and never
uh
never pay it you don't need to pay
attention to them I mean the main thing
to do and you're not going to pick the
bottom and you're not gonna nobody else
can pick it for you or anything of A
Sort you've got to be prepared when you
buy a stock to have it go down 50
percent
or more and be comfortable with it as
long as you're comfortable with the
holding and I pointed out
I think a year maybe two years ago in
the annual report uh well just the one
before this most recent one I pointed
out that there have been
three times in berkshire's history
when the price of Berkshire stock went
down 50 percent three different times
now if you hold it on borrowed money you
would you know you could have been
cleaned out uh there wasn't anything
wrong with Berkshire uh when those three
times occurred but
if you're going to if you're going to
look at them
the price of the stock
uh and think that you have to act
because it's doing this or that or
somebody else tells you why you know how
can you stay with that when something
else is going up or anything it really
you've got to be in the right
psychological position and frankly some
people are not really careful some
people are more subject to fear than
than others it's it it
it's like it's like the virus it strikes
uh some people with uh much greater
ferocity than than others and and fear
is uh
there is something I really
never felt financially but but uh I
don't think Charlie's felt it either but
uh
some people can handle psychology if you
can't handle it psychologically then you
really should have known sucks because
you're going to buy and sell them at the
wrong time and you should not count on
somebody else
telling you that you you should do
something you understand yourself if you
don't understand it yourself you're
going to be affected by the next person
you talk to and uh so you should you
should
be in a position to hold and I don't
know whether today is a great day to buy
stocks I know it will work out over 20
or 30 years I don't know whether it'll
work out over two years at all I have no
idea whether you'll be ahead or behind
on a sock you buy on Monday morning what
do you think the lessons are of the last
couple cycles that you've seen from an
investor standpoint we've got a lot of
young kids out there you've lived
through multiple Cycles in the in the 50
to 60 years plus you've been doing
investing in 70 years yeah what are the
lessons and what you know these are
young people what should they take away
the lessons are the people will continue
to make the same mistakes they've made I
mean it humans and whether it doesn't
correlate to IQ particularly I mean they
when they get
when they get greedy
and we have this huge bubble in the most
important asset the American public has
housing I mean so you had a huge bubble
in something you could borrow heavily
against so you could run a margin
account effect on a house instead of
socks and and the conditions got very
lacks and so when that bubble popped but
people came into that gradually when
they get fearful it happens all at once
I mean when everybody wants when people
get scared they all want to leave at one
time and we had them all want to leave
at one time and we'll have that'll
happen again it'll happen with a
different set of circumstances but but
the human animal
will keep behaving pretty much the way
it has in the past so we will have
periodic
uh
uh recessions will have an occasional
Panic which does not all recessions
don't come from panics but uh uh but the
good news is if you look at the 20th
century
in the 20th century we had two world
wars we had the Great Depression we had
the flu epidemic we had the we had the
Cold War we had the atom bomb you name
it
the Dow Jones average went from 66 to 11
497. you know with all these terrible
things happening supposedly at various
times America works and uh well I when I
bought my first stock when I was 11 that
was in the spring of 1942 and that was a
couple months after Pearl Harbor and we
were getting clobbered in the Pacific at
Corregidor and Baton I mean the death
march of baton and in in in in the
European theater the the blitz of
England was on and but and the Dow was
at about 100 but just look at where we
are now I mean the country really works
uh the trick is I mean it seems to me
the obligation of a society is
prosperous as ours is to figure out how
nobody gets left too far behind but you
don't have to worry about the system
working but you will have
you will have periodic recessions and
you will have an occasional Panic
brought on by something that who knows
where it comes from you know and uh
thing to remember at that time I wrote
an op-ed piece in in the New York Times
and in the fall of 2008 and I said you
know that that the country will come
back you know it'll go through a big
recession and everything but it'll come
back and it's coming back there's two
kinds of of items that people buy and
think they're investing one really is
investing in the other is it if you buy
something a farm an apartment house
or an interest in the business and look
to the asset itself to determine whether
you've done something what the farm
produces what what the business earns
and so on uh you don't really care what
the stock market's open you can do that
on a private basis in fact you do it on
a private basis if you buy a farmer
apartment house generally and it's a
perfectly satisfactory investment you
look at the investment itself to deliver
the return to you now if you buy
something uh
like uh Bitcoin or or some some
cryptocurrency you don't really you
don't have anything that's producing and
you're just hoping the next guy pays
more and the next and you only feel
you'll find the next guy to pay more if
he thinks he's going to find somebody
that that's going to pay the more now if
you ban trading in farms you could still
buy farms and have a perfectly decent
investment if you ban trading in in
apartment houses or even in equities if
you ban trading at Berkshire Hathaway
for the next five years our investors
would do fine you know overtime and but
if you ban trading and tulip bulbs you
know or if you're band trading in in
some Bitcoin which nobody knows exactly
what it is uh people would say well why
in the world would I buy it and you
aren't investing when you do that you're
speculating there's nothing wrong with
it if you want to gamble somebody else
will come along and pay more money
tomorrow that's one kind of game that is
not investing there can be all kinds of
wonderful investment opportunities out
there that I don't understand I don't
know what cocoa beans you're going to do
next year here you know maybe you know
but I don't know I I don't know what I
don't know what uh crude oil is going to
sell for it but I don't have to know I
just have to know the things I have to
know what I know I have to know where
the limits of my understanding are what
I call my what my circle of competence
is and if I'm only able to evaluate five
percent of the businesses in the world
no problem I just stay within that five
percent and try and find something and
that's most people get in trouble
because
in Investments because they well they
get itchy you know they can't discipline
themselves and they hear about other
people making money nothing upsets
people so much as they hear about their
friends making money I mean it that
that's very destructive to discipline
because they think you know I'm smarter
than that guy next door and he just just
bought that new car with the money made
trading stocks on the internet so why
can't I well the answer is you can't
over time you will lose money if you
trade stocks actively and uh it's it's
hard to exercise the discipline
but anytime you buy something
you should be able to take out a
one-page sheet of paper
and say I'm buying General Motors it's
65. I'm buying General Electric 150
because
and you should write down the reasons if
you can't if you can't fill out the
sheet if it's because somebody told me
about it at a cocktail party last night
that's not good enough if it's because
my broker told me about it that's not
good enough
yeah it's uh you've got to have a reason
for thinking that it makes an
intelligent investment you do the same
thing if you're buying a farm or an
apartment house if you're buying a farm
you'd say I'm buying this farm at a
thousand dollars an acre because I think
I can earn sixty dollars an acre on it
if corn sells and such and such and
soybean cells and such and such and
yield and such and such and you'd figure
it out
it's the same reason you buy businesses
and when you buy stocks you're buying a
little piece of a business
and that's probably the most important
thing to remember in investing is that
when you are buying a stock you're
buying a little piece of the business
and if if you were buying it at an
attractive price for the business for
the whole business you're going to make
money and if you aren't you know over
time you won't make money you have to
have the attitude that you're buying
part of a business and not that you're
buying something that Wiggles around on
a charter that has resistance zones or
200-day moving averages or that you buy
puts or calls on or anything like that
you're buying part of a business and if
you buy intelligently into a business
you're going to make money
and then you have to buy something that
in my view which you do if you're buying
a business that you're not going to get
a quote on
for five years that they're going to
close the stock exchange tomorrow for
five years and you'll be happy owning it
as a business if you owned Coca-Cola it
didn't really make any difference in
1920 if it went public the important
thing was what I was doing with
customers and you probably would have
been better off if there wasn't any
Market in it for 30 or 40 years because
then you wouldn't have gotten tempted to
sell it that and you just watched the
business and you'd watch it grow and and
you'd feel happy so you the the proper
attitude toward investing is is much
more important than any technical skills
you've been famous for your investment
strategy on basically that follows the
opposite side that principles invest
when the chips are down and brought it
up
that served you well so what's your
favorite your favorite uh time that you
were able to accomplish that when you
caught somebody down and and uh well I I
always think my favorite time's gonna be
tomorrow
but I it it's it's always been fun you
know and and uh there's a company here
in in Washington called Geico you know
and I I first got exposed to that in
1950 I was I was 20 years I was 19 years
or it was 51 I'm sorry I was 20 years
old and uh I came down here and and I
came down on a Saturday uh because I'd
learned that my
Professor who I worshiped at Columbia
named Ben Graham was the chairman I got
down here and the door was locked and I
went to the building because it was
Saturday and I pounded on the door and
some janitor let me in and a marvelous
fellow named Laura Mar Davidson spent
four hours with me teaching me all about
insurance and he he helped me so much in
life but you're gonna get it you're
going to get helped by some wonderful
people in life it's a great thing to to
remember later on when you have to be my
age that you know all the help you've
received from different people because
uh uh Nobody Does it alone Obama got in
trouble when he said that in the
campaign that you know Nobody Does It by
themselves nobody does do it by
themselves we all sit in the shade of
trees that were planted by others so
it's publicly I think to plant a few
trees ourselves if we've had good luck
uh it's
it's been a great ride but it's not over
there's no question that that that
capitalism
as it gets more advanced will widen the
gap between the people that have Market
skills whatever that market demands
and uh and others unless government does
something in between which say the
earned income tax credit or all kinds of
things and and I think that's a proper
function so I would I would I would say
that if people
that it isn't some diabolical plot or
anything but look at it this way if you
go back to eighteen hundred and eighty
percent of the people were farmers and
you were the best farmer in Omaha and I
was the worst the difference in our
value might be two to one you might be
worthwise as much if we aren't there
picking horn or whatever we might be
doing or planning but
now
there's we'll say two million times but
there's 30 million American males
between 20 and 35.
and if you're
in the top one tenth of one percent in
basketball ability or football
eventually or baseball you aren't worth
anything
if you're in the top 100th of one
percent you're getting close
so
if that's if the payoff is huge because
some guy discovered television many
years ago and another guy discovered pay
TV or cable and then pay TV so that your
talents
where Ted Williams got twenty thousand
dollars a year for batting 406. your
talents now if you if you make the
majors still doesn't pay well in the
miners but if you finally get to that
100th of one percent now you're you're
worth millions and uh one tenth of one
percent you can I don't think you can
just play Sandlot ball and so you get
this pushing of extreme rewards to
people who are very very good at
something the market demands and people
demand entertainment they demand people
apparently that Arbitrage Securities you
know I mean there's all there's certain
Specialties and uh
that isn't because a bunch of people are
sitting in a room deciding we're going
to figure out how to take it away from
the poor or anything like that it's
because of the market system but we want
the market system to keep functioning
that way but we don't want people left
behind in a society where you've got
sixty thousand dollars plus of GDP per
capita it
and that
the people on the on in the lower half
have been getting falling behind the
gains overall achieved by the country
and we've they aren't worse off than
they were 20 years ago they're somewhat
better off and they're better off
they're better off because of things
like an iPhone I mean you know that's
that's something that's terribly useful
and and everybody I get the benefits of
search you know for nothing it'll
basically and but
the ultimate tension is how do you keep
a system that produces and incredible
benefits for everybody you know Sports
is an easy example because we all like
to watch them we don't want to watch a
bunch of guys like you and me
so that's where the money is but that
didn't exist 200. how do we address that
we address it through things like the
earned income tax credit and we address
it so that anybody that worked 40 hours
a week
and as a couple of kids that they don't
need a second job in the family and they
can have a decent life does that mean
increasing the minimum wage it means
increasing the earned income tax credit
because I think that's a better system
yeah what they need is more money in
their pockets yeah now you can do more
money in the pocket through a minimum
wage but you don't have work have as
many people working you need something
so they have money in their pocket right
and we can do that and that does require
a in my view it requires higher taxes on
people that
where they were born into this world
with peculiar talents that that
marvelously now and then 200 years ago
they would have been out there picking
corn with me can you take the higher
taxes on wealthy people and put it
directly to the Earned Income Tax Credit
well you could I mean because people
complain oh my taxes are going well
they're squandered yeah nobody likes
taxes yeah but if you put had a program
where it was earmarked well that's
that's what people do in there
whether on the debate stage you know
currently it's the Democrats and they
they tell you all their new programs and
how they'll pay for it but they don't
tell you how they're going to pay for
the ones are already there nobody's
discussed the trillion dollar deficit we
have so to talk about how you're going
to introduce some new but basically
you don't want to run deficits
indefinitely that increase the
relationship that the G because there's
there's some point at which that causes
real problems although we haven't seen
it a lot of places that you might expect
to see it but
this country has
the the productive capacity
to let people like me live
extraordinarily well or sports stars or
entertainment stars all kinds of good
managers whatever
and still make sure that nobody is
really
left so that two people have to work and
you have to hold two jobs and you wonder
how you're going to feed your kids if
you're if you're working you know 750 an
hour doesn't do it and ten dollars an
hour doesn't do it but we can do it we
have the resources to do it would I be
wrong to suggest the thing you worry
most about is whether after you are gone
that that culture remains as it is that
you have in a since made Berkshire
strong enough to exist without you yeah
I don't worry about that I worried about
it over the years which is why I did a
bunch of things that I think uh ensure
that future but I uh that's always the
question I mean you know you've seen all
kinds of great companies topple for one
you once said to me and to others you
have to make your company idiot-proof
because at some point some idiot will
run it yeah well that may be even the
case now I mean but if someone has said
I think that the thing you worry most
about is whether Berkshire will be
intact 20 years after years well I don't
worry about but I care about it yeah no
and since I care about it
I I've put things in place which I think
almost ensure that that Berkshire will
be a lot better 20 years after I'm gone
than it is now they've got to crank in
interest rates because everything in
valuation gets back to interest rates
and if you take the U.S treasury bill
now which is uh
we'll call it 80 basis appointment is
what maturity that means the U.S
treasury bill is selling at 125 times
earnings now if that if your
alternatives to buy something at 125
times earnings or a good business whose
earnings will probably increase at 15 or
18 times earnings you've got to measure
it against the the uh
the risk it isn't really a risk-free
instrument but the the standard rate and
you know in 1982 you know the the rates
got up 15 or whereabouts and that makes
a lot of difference I mean you've got a
choice with money what do you do with it
in Europe if you put it in the bank you
know you you will be charged for having
it there it's better to keep it under
your mattress so uh it's you've got a
choice every day is what you do and I I
think equities are are cheaper than than
fixed dollar Investments some of our
managers are in businesses that are just
much easier I mean we we bought into
a variety of businesses people are
obviously influenced by
what day arrangements are
elsewhere that wouldn't be human if if
they weren't and uh
trying to
trying to come to the right answer when
you have different degrees of capital
intensity different degree very
different degrees of
of basic profitability
uh
and how much you scale up based on size
because there is an incentive incentive
to grow businesses usually a business is
a
get much larger everybody from the CEO
down expects to earn more money for
something that we where they really
bring the same amount of
amount of intensity and work and boiling
to it it is really a tough question I
think that
that
if you engage
compensation Consultants that public
companies which they all do they're
going to
they're going to recommend things that
cause them to have CEOs recommend them
to other companies it's just you you're
working against
human nature
when you have an arrangement like that I
would say that we have
obviously kept a very very very
high percentage of the managers that we
hope to have stay with us in fact just
about a hundred percent it's uh and I
think people do like
they do like to make their own decisions
they do like recognition
you know they they
most people
respond they like doing a good job and
they like they like the fact that we
understand it and compensation is part
of that
but it's not the whole thing and uh
I wish I could give you some precise
formulas is business school worth it
depends on the person that uh much more
than it depends on the school I mean I I
wouldn't worry some people are going to
get a lot out of advanced education and
some people are going to get very little
and uh I don't even think it's important
that every person go to college at all I
mean we have all kinds of jobs at 70 or
so thousand a year 80 000 a year that
College training is is not of use and
and I I actually was not keen on going
to college
myself yeah my dad uh kind of Jolly me
into it he could get me to do anything
but if they'd had an SAT tested those
days he would have taken the test for me
but I knew I could have a good time and
I liked investing and I didn't really
feel I I could read the books you know
it's a big commitment to take four years
and the cost involved and maybe the
loans involved and everything and I
think depending on what your interests
are in life uh I don't I don't think
it's for everybody I think it's for a
lot of people but there ought to be a
reason you're going and I didn't really
see much reason it's very important to
surround your people yourself with
people that are the better than you are
you are going to move in the direction
of the people you associate with so you
constantly
I've been enormously Lucky in that
respect I mean I've I've just had
teachers and and friends and a spouse
that
really was a better person I was and I
had enough sense to learn from these
people that that life went better if you
behave better yourself at the uh it took
a while
the uh so I
I advise you
to seek out
as your partner in business your partner
in life whatever it may be look for the
people that actually
uh are examples to you rather than
somebody that you need to you think you
need to straighten out yourself and
simple rules like that
the lighting customers working through
other people
associating with people that will will
cause you to move in a better path than
you might otherwise have
they will take you so far in life that
uh
it's hard to believe can you help us
understand how to cultivate how to
cultivate that mindset of being
comfortable saying no being comfortable
delegating this is something that we
found with our members is especially
difficult for young women it's tough um
and we'd love to just hear your take on
that and maybe any advice you have to
share about that I met Bill Gates Bill
Gates in 1991 and when I did it we had a
great time talking he thought he was
going to hate it and I I wasn't too keen
on it either and about 10 hours later we
were still talking but but really got
him is when I pulled out this little
date book I'm probably the only guy in
the United States with one of these
still what oh you've got that over there
and I just flipped through it and you
know there's there's probably nothing in
it and Bill was really impressed by that
and uh you've got to keep control of
your time and and you won't keep control
of your time unless you can say no uh
you you can't let other people set your
agenda in life and of course I know I'm
in a very fortunate position on that
because I can in another way I'm not so
fortunate because more people ask me for
things and and and they're and they're
usually friends and they say well can't
you just make this one talk or attend
this one graduation or whatever it may
be uh you know you've gotta you just
have to develop the ability to say no
and and and do it a few times uh I mean
you know if a woman can't say no she's
in trouble right right and I mean is
this something that becomes easier over
time or how did you I don't think it's a
lot easier no it is it's there's a
couple there's a few things that really
just are uncomfortable enough I've the
thing I like the thing I dislike the
most the the only thing I really dislike
in connection job is if I have to fire
somebody I mean that does not get easy
for the easier for me as life has gone
wrong and saying no is not like firing
people but it's got a little bit of the
same aspect to it it's not easy to say
no particularly to a friend uh but I
will have every day three or four or
five requests to do something and I I
can't do them all you know and uh
but I'm not promising it gets easier
but but just keep doing it otherwise
other people will be running your life
you don't necessarily
get it right the exactly right the first
time I mean the car leasing business you
know basically you were competing on the
cost of money to finance cars and and
it's very hard to Delight a customer
when you just give them the car and tell
them to send you a monthly check for
five years and you'll be back at that
time so his talents were being wasted
basically in that business but at the
age of 40
with all of that experience behind him
he found
he he found the golden key and he he
took a very ordinary business
and turned it into an absolutely
extraordinary uh operation uh just like
Mrs B Rose Bumpkin did uh with furniture
and
the
he didn't worry
about whether the Federal Reserve was
going to tighten or ease
he didn't worry about whether the stock
market was up or down yesterday
you know he didn't he didn't worry about
the things he couldn't change
but he did worry he did Focus
on the one thing he couldn't change and
that was the customer's experience
and I have seen
uh
the one I didn't The One That Got Away
Enterprise I went down to Florida and
tried to talk him into selling the
Berkshire and he was smart enough not to
do it
probably the value of the company is
quadrupled since I made that visit uh
but he he was smart enough to see
that he would find that business Henry
Ford as you may know failed twice before
he started the Ford Motor Company in
1903 I mean the the test isn't whether
you get the greatest
business idea in the world the first
time out the test is whether you keep
learning as you go along what your
strengths are and what you can do for
your customers what you can bring
especially to the party
and to do that
uh you need you need
the education that that I know you've
received uh through ten thousand small
businesses but you need
a genuine
a genuine desired day in
Day Out
to Delight the customer
I've never I've never seen a business
and I've seen a lot of businesses but
I've never seen one that Delights the
customer
that that doesn't succeed I mean what
you want is that customer the next day
when they think do I want to rent a car
or do I want to buy some furniture
what goes through their mind
you know it's the place where they've
had a great experience I don't know what
I paid for this
type actually probably if somebody gave
it to me but for the purposes of the
speech I will say I I have no idea but
what I or the shirt I'm wearing or this
but I do know I will remember
how I was treated
when I bought it I mean you long forget
about the price but you never forget
whether you had a good experience or a
poor experience uh with the purchase
experience it's absolutely true in my
view that that uh
you can and should understand
human behavior
better
as you do get older you just have more
experience with it and
I don't think you can read
Charlie and I read every book we could
on every subject we were interested in
you know and we were very young and we
learned it
an enormous amount just from what from
others studying the lives of other of
other people and but I don't think you
can really
I don't think they can get to be an
expert on human behavior At All by
reading books no matter what your IQ is
no matter who the teacher is and I think
that you really do learn a lot
about human behavior sometimes you have
to learn it by having multiple
experiences
um I think you'll I think I actually
think I
despite all the other shortcomings and I
can't do mental arithmetic as fast as I
used to and I can't I can't read as fast
as I used to but I I do think that I
know a lot more about
human behavior than I did when I was 25
or 30. how Warren has changed from
decade to decade to decade well you have
a sense of that I've gotten Dumber but
I've gotten wiser
okay that's that's a nice phrase and but
what does it mean it means that it means
that I can't add a group of numbers
remotely as fast as I used to be able to
I can't remember sometimes when I walk
upstairs but I I while I'm walking up
the stairs I think about something else
so by the time I get to the top of
stairs I don't remember why the hell I
walked upstairs it means I forget names
so easily it means that I can't read as
fast as I used to read I am a decaying
machine that still feels wonderful but I
can't hear as well I can't see as well
my balance is as good but it doesn't
interfere
with my happiness my work anything
especially your work
well I mean clearly your happiness but
but it doesn't you know you're saying
you're outstanding it doesn't interfere
with anything that ages I can get on a
plane go anyplace you know I can I can
do
anything as long as you don't ask me to
dance
or juggle or you know
or even remember you know who'd I meet
yesterday
but in terms of the doing the job that
you do allocating capital
I I can actually do that as well as ever
as ever yeah that that sounds awesome
but but better than that do you do it
today better than you did it 20 years
ago yeah
I've got a different set of
opportunities you are joining us on a
day when we have watched the stock
market continue to set new highs the s p
uh the Russell and the NASDAQ the Dow's
not far off and the question we always
ask you is do stocks look expensive to
you at these prices well they are
definitely if you had your choice
between buying and holding a 30-year
bond for 30 years or holding
a basket of American stocks there's just
no question you're going to do better
holding stocks so it's it's more
attractive than considerably more
attractive than fixed income securities
that doesn't mean they're going to go up
or down tomorrow or next week or next
year but over time a bunch of businesses
that are earning High Returns on Capital
are going to beat a bond that's fixed it
roughly three percent for 30 years
and I I it's not my field of especially
but but
actually they look stocks generally
which are their businesses they're
American businesses 30 trillion worth of
them and they look cheaper than than uh
generally real estate you're sitting
with some cash in your body you've had
savings and the question is what do you
do with it you can buy a duplex next
door and run it out to people and do
fine over time or uh you can you can buy
a small piece of farmland or something
of a sword or or you can put it into
something fixed income bonds or Bank
deposits or whatever it may be and uh
stocks if you look at American equities
American Business is earning a lot of
money relative to the capital put in and
the reason stocks are worth a whole lot
more than they were 20 years ago or 50
years ago or 100 years ago is companies
have plowed back part of the earnings
with the money to get it all out in
interest you know you get your three
percent or whatever it is and that's
what you have with stocks you're going
to maybe a three percent dividend but
they're plowing money back with their
repurchasing shares or doing something
and over time that just makes a huge
difference the most important thing
uh
aside from the things I've talked about
already is it's really who you associate
with you want to associate with people
that are better than you are I mean
basically you'll go in the direction of
the people that you associate with and
and you want to have the right Heroes uh
you want people if you want to emulate
somebody you better pick very carefully
who you want to emulate and uh and when
obviously you can't pick your parents uh
they're going to have enormous influence
on you but you don't get a choice on
that but you get choices as you go down
the line and you
who you uh who you admire who you who
who you want to copy and the most
important for most people in terms of
that decision is their spouse it's also
important in terms of a partner in
business with the partner in life is is
the most important one you want to pick
a spouse that's a little that better
than you are
and then he or she and Paul and you hope
they don't figure it out too fast
Charlie Munger and I have been making
stock decisions and business decisions
uh one way or another together now for
55 years
we have never let
well the macro doesn't enter into it nor
just political we haven't we have not
made decisions differently because one
party or the other is in power we have
not made decisions based on whether we
thought interest rates were going to go
up or down or or you know what was going
to happen with labor negotiation
someplace you know you don't want to
give up what you know how to do
because of the opinions which you don't
know whether right or not and which are
going to be transitory in any events so
you really go out there every day and do
whatever makes the most sense so when we
buy the auto dealerships last week uh we
don't factor in anything
about the FED about the deadlock in
politics about what's going on around
the world those are all important things
but they don't affect whether those
dealerships which we're buying to own
100 years they don't affect whether
they're going to make money in the year
2024 or 2034 or 2044 and the important
thing is whether we get a good business
with good management at a sensible price
it would be a tough consideration for me
if I were going to school whether I
wanted to not only invest
I'm done at college but I want to invest
the four years I didn't want to go to
college that much when I got out of high
school but not only the four years but
if I had to incur
uh you know hundreds of thousands of
dollars in students I I don't know which
decision I would make
uh no it's it
higher education is really expensive and
we've helped out many thousands of
students in the Gates Foundation has
done the same thing and and other the
foundations that I support but but it's
just expensive it's very is it still
worth it
it depends on the individual
it depends on the individual more than
the school I mean it uh
there's a lot to learn in those four
years I mean there's a lot you can learn
in those four years and whether you do
or not depends on more on the individual
I don't think it I don't think it makes
sense for everybody to go to college you
know
and I'm not so sure it made sense for me
to go to college really come on no I'm
not kidding I I I I don't know I mean I
I learned a lot by reading
and
and you know I spent three or four years
and well kind of graduate school four
years uh
that I could have been doing other
things and there were a lot of
intelligent things to do then who knows
uh no I I don't think it was
essential I mean I I had some wonderful
people I met through it main thing when
I went to Columbia though with with
taking pentagrams because I already knew
what he was going to say I mean I I read
it I understood you know I mean he was a
very good writer but it was
inspirational it was inspirational
margin it wasn't educational if you can
in life working what you love with
people you love and you know it comes
back at you love is something you can't
get rid of if you give it to other
people you get it back if you try to
hold on to it disappears I mean unlike
anything anything else in the world and
we literally
we put on this whole show we've got
probably three to four hundred people
from our subsidiaries coming in we have
everybody in the world wanting hotel
rooms we've got them I mean you know all
the things that go with having 40 000
plus people come and having a 200 000
square foot exhibition Hall and and
everything else and that basically is
handled by the people in our office
we've got 25 people in the office we had
25 last year we got 25 this year exactly
the same people not one change of a
person this is a company with 350
000 or so people around the world
working and added 16 billion to sales
last year but we did not add a person
and our CFO is down there working I mean
he is working with projectionists or
whatever they have up there making sure
this matters right everybody our tax the
woman that is in charge of our taxes you
name it everybody pitches in and they
won't have a good time how come you
haven't bought Amazon is there still
time to buy would you still buy it oh I
I always admired Jeff I mean I met him
20 years ago or so and and
I thought it was something special but I
didn't realize you could go from books
to it what's happened there no I I mean
he had a vision and executed in an
incredible way
something that would not have you know
that but there's a lot of games I miss I
would have missed you know I would have
missed Microsoft even if I got into no
bill earlier or something those just
aren't my games I don't worry about the
things that I missed that are outside my
circle of competence of evaluating I I
do I have missed things that were within
my circle and that's a terrible mistake
those are my biggest mistakes you
haven't seen them and but I don't it's
not a mistake because I miss Netscape or
something like that at all I would say
that maybe five percent of the companies
or ten percent of the companies that
most are within an area my circle of
competence there's something I should be
able to understand well that's certainly
a possibility I mean it's a possibility
under me it's a possibility under the
successor his question of can you invest
truly large sums reasonably well you
can't do it as well as you can do small
sums so there's no question about that
but uh
we will have to see how that works out
over many years because certain years
lots of opportunities huge opportunities
present themselves and and other years
are are totally dry holes so
it's not a judgment you can make in a
one-year period or a three-year period
it's certainly a judgment you can make
over time though and and I personally
my estate will will uh
have basically nothing but Berkshire in
it for some time as it gets to dispersed
to philanthropies and I have a section
in there which says to the trustees in
effect who manage it I have a I have a
section in there that says that ignore
the uh your or your your your your
exempt is from my standpoint uh from the
law that trustees normally should
diversify and do all that sort of thing
and I I want the entire amount that they
have to be kept in Berkshire as they
distributed over time to the
philanthropies and I don't worry at all
about the fact I I would like to have a
very large sum go to the philanthropies
and I I don't worry at all about the
fact that it essentially will all be in
Berkshire and I'm willing to make that
decision While I'm Alive which will
continue for some years after I die so I
have a lot of confidence in the ability
of the Berkshire culture to endure and
that we have the right people to make
sure that that happens but I'm betting
my entire
net worth on that and and that doesn't
give me pause at all I rewrite my will
every few years and I write it I write
it the same way in respect to the
Berkshire Holdings by far the best
investment you can make is in yourself I
mean that for example communication
skills I tell those students that come
that they're going to
graduate schools and business and
they're learning all these complicated
formulas and all that if they just learn
to communicate better and both in
writing and in person they increase
their value at least 50 percent now I
mean
if you can't communicate somebody he
says you know it's like winking at a
girl in the dark nothing happens you
know basically and and you have to be
able to get get forth your ideas and uh
and that's
that's relatively easy I did it myself
with the Dale Carnegie of course some
people wish I'd take it a shorter course
now my answer is my talking later on but
it it's just hugely important and you if
you invest in yourself nobody can take
it away from you you famously passed on
Intel when it was getting started I
thought I knew Bob Bob noise pretty well
and we bought it we bought the converts
when they were private or just uh
because of Bob we bought them at
Grinnell college and and the indominator
now College went from 8 million to a
billion dollars in about
12 or 14 years so and it told intel was
a help on that but I you know in the end
I don't worry about things I don't
understand I mean I think it was Tom
Watson senior said I'm no genius but I'm
smart in spots and I stay around those
spots you know and that there's a lot to
that and knowing your circle of
competence is where that perimeter is is
enormously important and you know the
fact that there are there's all kinds of
things I can't do and there's plenty of
companies I can't analyze but I don't
have to worry about that it's very
important to have the right framework
you need you need
you need to have an approach to
investing that sound and Graham's
approach is is simple uh but some people
adopt to it and and which I did
immediately and and most people don't
um but if you have the right philosophy
you will find Opportunities
uh as you go through the next 20 30 40
50 years I didn't want to go to college
so I I don't know whether I would have
done better or worse
divide just quit After High School
you know and read the books I read and
all of that uh
I think that if you run into a
a few great teachers
and they really
change the way you see the world of some
degree you know you're lucky and you can
find them and you can find them in
Academia and you can find them in
ordinary life
and I I've been extraordinarily lucky
and having great teachers including
Charlie I mean Charlie's been a
wonderful teacher and you know the any
place you can find somebody that that
gives you insights into things you
didn't understand before maybe it makes
you a better person than you would have
been before you know you get that's very
lucky and you want to make the most of
it if you can fight it and I could make
the most of it and if you can find it in
the rest of your life make the most of
it and I'd rather
by a an attractive business then buy our
own stock
at its intrinsic business value if our
stock gets well below that
I've still got this strong and I can do
both fortunately but but
why how an executive
can pay say we're going to spend 10
billion dollars buying stock and then
not paying the attention to the price at
which they buy it they wouldn't buy any
other business that way uh and and
so we're probably sensitive on it on the
other hand when the price is right
there's no easier way to make money for
your shareholders why get involved in
something with the decisions every day
are are terrible when you can get into a
business where they're very very easy
it's much more fun to sell Coca-Cola and
everybody's smiling as my partner
Charlie marker says we haven't learned
how to make a silk purse out of a
Salazar we have enough trouble making
some purse out of silk you've been
famous for your investment strategy on
basically that follows the opposite side
that principles invest when the chips
are down and brought it up
that served you well so what's your
favorite your favorite uh time that you
were able to accomplish that when you
caught somebody down and and uh well I I
always think my favorite time's gonna be
tomorrow
but I it it's it's always been fun you
know and and uh there's a company here
in in Washington called Geico you know
and I I first got exposed to that in
1950 I was I was 20 years I was 19 years
or it was 51 I'm sorry I was 20 years
old and uh I came down here and and I
came down on a Saturday uh because I'd
learned that my
Professor who I worship the Colombia
named Ben Graham was the chairman I got
down here and the door was locked and I
went to the building because it was
Saturday and I pounded on the door and
some janitor let me in and a marvelous
fellow named Lorimer Davidson spent four
hours with me teaching me all about
insurance and he he helped me so much in
life but you're gonna get it
you're going to get helped by some
wonderful people in life it's a great
thing to to remember later on when you
have to be my age that you know all the
help you've received from different
people because uh Nobody Does it alone
Obama got in trouble when he said that
in the campaign that you know Nobody
Does It by themselves nobody does do it
by themselves we all sit in the shade of
trees that were planted by others so
it's publicly I think the plant a few
trees ourselves if we've had good luck
uh it's
it's been a great ride but it's not over
[Music]
oh I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
success rules from Ray dalio check the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there know yourself Follow
Your Passion make your work and passion
the same thing while considering the
money part because money will get you
freedom and choice and be able to